so let's go and talk more about the
linear regression we already done a lot
of uh lot of work hopefully a lot of a
lot of understanding what we are after
so basically we are after finding some
sort of a correlation between our uh
independent data points our dependent
data points that we measured in some in
some experiments Where We Are are also
heading to is
to know find uh understand that there
are some experiments uh which are better
conducted some experiments that are
worse conducted there are some variables
that are better to be chosen into some
models some uh variables are uh not a
good idea to choose for a particular
model so this is where where we where we
should have
but before that uh we have
uh we have LLY spoken about transforming
uh we already did some kind of half step
we already talk about uh Transforming
Our linear
regression task uh from having all these
ugly sums in some in some matrices and
uh doing some uh what what have we done
like some specific differentiation with
respect to one parameter of our
regression second parameter of our
aggression the good new good news and
what will help us is that we know
matrices and and vectors and this will
very very ease uh ease our our work
um yep
so we started
to to express uh
our
uh our our data points uh in the in the
in the vector form so what we can for
example imagine we have one independent
variable and we have conducted capital N
of experiments yeah we have capital N of
of the of the data points and now if
there will be more of these independent
variables there was some example
temperature concentration maybe some
nonlinear transformations of
these of these uh variables well we can
keep this Vector form so we have still
the vector of the uh experiment data
experimental data from one to n but we
can now can we can now stack them uh
together and we BAS basically basically
form a form a
matrix uh in more general form we would
be stacking so now this X1 would
represent like the first variable which
has which is n n measurements this is
looks bit messy in the in the beginning
but if once we are comfortable with uh
with the fact that okay our our data are
in some Matrix then we can just work
with this with this Matrix here this uh
Matrix we will we will call it capital x
and
uh and uh yeah okay we have it here I
didn't have to write it
there we will call it a capital capital
x and we can
even express
for example our now our prediction
equation so if we have this Matrix X
remember all the
variables and uh and all the experiments
in the corresponding rows variables in
the columns then this x So-Cal regressor
Matrix we can quite nicely uh multiply
with our parameter Vector p and uh we
obtain a vector of our of our prediction
so each of the N experimental data
points that we measured the Y without
head there will be a prediction of this
y
hat is this clear understood digest it
everybody comfortable with that or
no now yes
I will take it as as yes at least
Adriana was
nodding thank you good
so if we now now have this uh this form
of our of our prediction equation we can
build our Matrix Vector form of the of
the least squares of the uh Le squares
that we that we have done for the linear
regression when we had just
just the one one line with with two two
parameters now there can be any any
number of uh any number of parameters
and lastly we also seen that writing
this Vector transpose the same Vector
would mean would mean the sum of squares
of
the of the components of that of that
vector yeah for example for example here
x transpose X would be would correspond
to the sum of the squares of the
components of the of the vector
X so let's hope this is well digested uh
so let's wipe these guys we should we
should get into this into this formula
very very very quickly and very very
easily so uh let's uh let's first uh
well what we have we have some
multiplications of the or the SC scalar
multiplication of the of the
vectors right it should be scalar
because we are just the the sum of sum
of square is just the Scala value we are
just minimizing the the of squares so
let's first find out how how we can
write this multiplication
down how we can how we can do the
multiplication
um how to do
that well if we have the the trans the
transpose of the of the first bracket uh
we can transfer this transpose on the
corresponding
vectors right so if I
write something like
this that's that represents the the
first bracket
that's that's okay
hopefully and the second bracket stays
the stays the
same now
please help me with some with some
multiplication what will be the what
will be the product of the of the two
brackets
the
vectors yes there will be a lot of
scalar multiplications because well our
we can just for for example like one
element uh not not one element let's
let's let's let's keep the vectors well
let's let's really do this uh what if if
we had uh if if if this so we have
vectors now if these were were scalers
then we would know yeah this would this
would transform into the into our famous
famous formula but uh yeah there is only
slight complication that we cannot
really write the the vector vector
square but uh but but still we can we
should obtain some equivalent of this of
the scalar form in the in the in the
vector world how would that how would
that look
like
yal to y
s it's it's not equal to y s but that's
this is the first term
yeah mhm
y y head y head
mhm right it's
just and
now
multip y
mhm the last one is plus
[Music]
mhm y head transpose y head exactly yeah
and we really obtained some some
equivalent of this formula so our first
term a let's say it was y so whenever we
would write a squ well we have y y
transpose times times y the same goes
for the for the last term the the Y
heads term and we also have some some
cross
terms
and but they are twoo different this is
these are two same and the question is
whether they are same same but different
but still the
same
uh
so are they same or are they are they
different terms what do you what do you
think who would say is the they are the
same hands
up who would say they are the
different okay and we have four four
people four people abstaining
well it's democracy you have you have
the right to to do so okay let's uh well
let's try
out so if we have
uh so y transpose time y head what would
it mean
our y's are always the column vectors so
of course the Y transpose will be a will
be a row Vector so we are getting to
this will be y1 Y 2 until YN multiplied
by y head 1 y head 2 y Head
n
okay I need to move more stuff oops
let's see how it
goes move okay uh Missing the square
where is the
square so what do we
get y1
time y1 head plus Y 2 Y 2 head plus and
so
on and so
forth yeah typical typical cross product
so it of course contains the the the
cross product of the of the elements of
the Y and and Y
head and our second
term y had transpose times
y
so no same
[Music]
same our Vector y hat and y1 Y 2 until
YN
what do we
get y y had 1 *
y1 y had 2 * 1 Y 2 and until y head why
had n y n so they are same same but
different but still the same which means
we can we can group these these two guys
together
and it's completely up to us how to how
to do that and uh let's let's say let's
say the the the the first first term uh
looks looks nicer we we will see we can
transform it back and forth whenever
whenever we
want um good
should be Al of course the the bracket
so we have y transpose
y- 2 * y
transpose y hat and plus y hat transpose
y
hat
okay so far so good
more
okay
why it's we we we don't have a a concept
of squaring a vector yeah so this is a
concept of of of squaring squaring a
vector um because well what would you
what would you like to uh to calculate
that usually when we are squaring the
numbers we are getting the distance from
the origin but this is still not the
quite the quite the distance to the
origin well it's distance squared
yeah it's
a it's a
bit let's just say we don't have the
this concept well defined like putting
the two as a upper index of of the
Y uh for good reasons it will it will
help us because we
uh yeah we would make use of this of
this
form so let's then introduce we still we
are still missing our variable P yeah so
we cannot really do the differentiation
yet uh let's introduce well our our
prediction uh equation so our y hat is
so our regressor
Matrix times P let's introduce
it wherever wherever we
need good let
me keep this one here that's our scaler
analog and
let's move this one a bit we will we
will need it in a in a
second good our y transpose y they are
staying this term this term stays and
will be relatively Irrelevant for our
determination of the of the parameters
doesn't contain parameters what we have
here uh - 2
* y head times oh sorry y y transpose
time y head which we now say is x *
p and our last term well that will be
that will be a bit bit complicated uh
what would y head transpose be equal to
in the terms of of
XMP oh Sor let's do it this
way feel the missing
places be transpose X transpose very
good B transpose X
[Music]
transpose ppose X transpose that was for
the Y head transpose yeah for the for
the first guy here the second guy is
just y y head so we just plug in x * B
yes or no Adam's face saying
her the as well
mhm yes
yes good one
thanks better thank you yeah tell me
when I
when I write it in a strange way good so
we have just just
used just use these
guys and well maybe it doesn't seem so
but we are now ready to do the
differentiation with respect to the to
the vector
P for that we would need couple of uh
couple of rules uh the differentiation
with respect to vectors it
again same same different still the same
a bit different than the differentiation
with the scalar variables so uh the
simple simple rules are if we have uh
what we what we what we will we will
need we we need some in the what do we
have in the in the scaler case we have a
constant times x if it's differentiated
with respect to scalar scalar X then we
get the constant back yeah in the vector
case this will be the representation
like the vector of constants is
multiplying is multiplying our x uh this
will be the case for for this guy here
our variable for the differentiation
will be will be p and well this cannot
be anything else this y transpose time x
must be a vector otherwise we would not
get the scalar objective function the
sum of sum of squares or part of the sum
of squares so if we do this
differentiation in the world of vectors
we actually
get get the the vector a a itself yeah
so here here it's here it's transpose
this is the uh sum or the
elements of vector X are weighted by the
elements of elements of a so we are
trying to find contribution for each of
the elements of X and the contributions
are for X1 it's A1 for for X2 it's it's
A2 yeah so that's why that's the
interpretation those will be the slopes
of of this function in the different
dimensions of of
X this is the let's say easier and
intuitive one the second uh formula from
this uh calculus with the vectors and
matrices we would need is to is to take
the derivative of this quadratic form
it's really called a quadratic form if
we have X transpose time a *
X yeah because that's that's what we
that's what we really really have there
the X transpose time x will be another
Matrix a very important Matrix that we
will uh talk talk today
about and
in what is this a scalar equivalent of
it's a scalar equivalent of constant
time x s yeah what do we expect what is
the derivative of x
squ with respect to X in the scalar
world
two
yes and uh this will depend a bit
because uh the the result
is the result looks like looks like
this which there is this notion of two *
2 * a but uh yeah it depends on on the
on the on the
Matrix uh what would be the what would
be the property so there will be a
special type of of Matrix where we can
just write 2 *
a
question just use the deration rule for
the
multiplication yes and we will and well
you will get the same thing yes uhhuh
yeah you would you would actually
transform in into into this form and you
will get this is it because because
first first you will get from this you
will get a transpose and from this part
you will you will get a
yeah exactly yeah if we are at the
mathematics lectures then then we would
we would derive it we uh we can there is
a very nice uh book called metric
cookbook all these kind of formulas are
are are there um what would be maybe a
special uh special case there there is a
special case when we can when we can
really have this even more similar
scaler scalar analog so what is the
property of Matrix a where I can write
it this
way even more General
hmmc yeah why because the if a would be
symmetric so
a
symmetric then a is equal to a transpose
right if we if we flip the what is it
rows and and columns well we will get
the same thing because it's a it's a Mir
mirror mirror image of of
itself H and of course well since I'm
mentioning it it might be that probably
this Matrix the X transpose X is
symmetric how can we find
out so is the X transpose X symmetric
give me the
proof now we can do the mathematical
mathematical proof very very easy
one and it's not proof by contradiction
or anything it's just the direct direct
proof how can we how can we deduce that
and the separation processes sucked all
the energy from you there will be the
there should be the energy balance of
the students done before and after the
the separation process is
examined uh well so let's just let's
just ask if this was a symmetric Matrix
then if we do it's
transpose then we should get the
equality so is this an
equality that's the question so what if
we apply our good old formula a * B
sorry a *
B transpose is equal to B transpose a
transpose what do we get
how is this
applied we take the second
Matrix we transpose it second Matrix
transpose
it
oops and we take the then the first
Matrix and we transpose it again again
what do we get X transpose transpose is
again the X itself our mathematical
proof proof was just was just done quote
erat
demonstr so lucky
case you look quite quite sad looking at
this at these matrices but we should be
very happy because this makes our life
much much much easier so we can just
apply this uh this uh
this simpler simpler result when doing
the
differentiation so let's do the
differentiation I will just copy this
this guy here if I am able to do
so why am I not able ah because I didn't
press copy right h that would
be that would be
necessary
copy what am I doing
wrong
copy
and
paste can I do it like this ah finally
we understand each other
[Music]
good so let's do the differentiation of
this term with respect to the to the
vector
p uh I do I do the first part you you
you do the rest there is no P here the
derivative of the Y transpose Y is
zero the second part which one which of
the formulas here we we can we can we
can apply minus 2 * * y transpose x * p
b is our our variable
here
M
then
turns yes
so let's do the differentiation with
respect to P we want it of course to be
to be zero
so uh two
remains No need no need to write
anything and then what should I
write
no oh sorry
no
so uh let's put it this
way
yeah this guy is the is the a transposed
so when we are when we are uh writing
the result we should write the a itself
soose
perfect X transpose
y SEC second term looks harder but it's
actually actually simpler what do we
what do we
apply how do we apply what's the result
so of course we can do some bracketing
to just realize the the same the same
form yeah so just
we know that our Matrix is symmetric so
we can
write a * X yeah or in our world our a
is X transpose
x uh do we need the bracket no we don't
need the bracket X transpose X time
P does it make sense to everybody
okay good thanks thank you for the for
the
confirmation um well doesn't look that
bad yeah just X Y XX B very relatively
relatively simple we can we can write
even more complicated complicated stuff
out out of this and it it will simplify
farther just be just believe me well
what we are actually actually having
here if we are now just a bit just a bit
creative can we
just put in Fr breaket
the we can but it but it won't help us
one why because we want to separate the
this guy it's a it's a it's a good good
good suggestion and it will it will show
us something something important uh we
can I'm just thinking because on the
left of the equation zero
mhm yeah but the division by
vectors or well you will you will end up
with what division by so X is not Square
Matrix so that's a bit
uh that's a bit not uh not easy to to do
but uh we can we can do it even even
simpler
uh what did actually our differentiation
uh
formulas uh tell us this result here
cannot be anything else well it's a
vector it cannot be anything else than
than a vector we we did a
differentiation with respect to the
vector P so we here need to have a
vector because it will tell us
contribution of each of the of the
elements of the of the vector B yeah
that's the vector which generally we can
call a what do we have here again our
differentiation formula is telling us
it's a * X Matrix times our variable
variable in question so if we just
re rewrite
this so X transpose x p and let's put
the negative hero on the on the other
side x transpose y well we just recover
our good old a * X is equal to B set of
linear algebraic equations which
probably you are you are not not not
surprised uh too much uh you probably
have have have seen it in your
optimization class yeah I have some
quadratic uh quadratic function in
multi-dimensional space I do the the
differentiation basically Newton's
formula is uh is uh is is doing this so
how do we solve a * X is equal to B
[Music]
back back backlash in in Matlab that's
correct okay so the Matlab
way
uh p is equal to and now what we are
what we are backs
slashing mhm
and
mhm matx is Now inverted why we are
backs slashing so we don't don't need
inverse so what we are doing mathematics
or or
okay X trans or or or Matlab yeah if we
do
Matlab this is one way if we write it in
the in a proper mathematics well we
just X transpose X
inverse x * x *
Y which is quite a quite quite an
interesting formula the the the
parameters the optimal parameters the
best
parameters uh
the parameters that that we calculate
are kind of just the linear combination
of our of our measurements with some
with some of course what we can expect
here there there there must be uh there
must be some some arithmetic
averages
um
this this can be a result but uh this
mlap can even even simplify farther this
uh sort of a sort of of operation has a
has a special
name remember or or recall that
our our Matrix X well our Matrix X the
regress matrix it's not squared yeah
because it holds it it has as many rows
as we have the number of experiments
observations and as many columns as the
number of number of parameters so it's
not Square in in
general and basically that's why we need
to need to do this do this trick to do
to make the X transpose time x will be
squared now we can apply the the square
root and and so on and the special name
for this is actually uh of this
operation of this whole underlined red
thing uh is a pseudo inverse pseudo
inverse of X of the of the Matrix Matrix
X in mass is usually uh denoted with
this kind of dagger like if you want to
stab somebody like a little
sword and uh Matlab way of doing
this it's just saying p is equal Al to
x/y yeah we don't need to don't need to
bother with with this one and this is
why we are we have done we have gone
gone through this uh tedious tedious uh
derivations because now what do what do
we what do we need to do if we have
Matlab python or whatever whatever
programming uh programming language at
our hand well we just collect our our
our independent U uh independent uh
variables uh in one Matrix capital x We
Gather our observations in the vector y
we call this this command one two three
three three hits of the keyboard enter
and and we and we have our our
parameters
so you mean okay the these these two
brackets
um and the X transpose disappear
yeah yeah some something something like
that uh
B no um so the the the slash command
looks so so simple uh yeah like just a
simple line what what is what is behind
that is actually whole decision three
which is uh so what does what does this
this do uh it will analyze what the what
the structure of this Matrix is so first
it will find out ah this Matrix is not
squared so I'm doing so I'm doing um
pseo inverse and then it will find out I
don't think it's it's doing exactly this
like because this takes a lot of
operations yeah multiplying uh uh maybe
maybe to to multiply uh matrix by itself
transposes can be somehow somehow
simplified but the definitely it's it's
not doing
uh well definitely it's doing inverse in
a uh in the most efficient way that that
that it can do uh so and there are
different algorithms based on how the
how the x is uh shaped this Matrix the
compositions uh stuff yeah so it's a
yeah pretty pretty pretty efficient way
and and also uh your uh Matlab is
usually usually telling you whenever you
are using uh
the whenever you you write either in
like inverse of a matrix or you or you
write uh head minus one where you want
to invert The Matrix it will usually
underline and say well better use the
back slash because it will be more
efficient more numerically stable this
is the reason the the backlash is the is
the most efficient
way because it
will it will really see what is what the
what is the Matrix Matrix
behind okay it's not that
not that we are giving you in the in the
exercises really really challenging
matrices but uh yeah maybe in your in
your either semestral projects or or
later you will you will find out that uh
it's it's good to good to know about
this backslash and and to use
it okay so ready for some more Matrix
stuff but I don't think it will
I hope it it it won't won't hurt more we
don't do the the differentiation with
the matrices and and vectors
uh let's just uh let's just maybe uh
first
analyze let just maybe first Analyze
This Matrix here it's very special it
holds a lot of uh lot of
information and uh we should we should
know about it this Matrix is actually
called
a covariance
matrix and
uh let's maybe dive into it uh into it
again or let's recall what is the shape
of the of The Matrix capital x how does
it look like I can just uh just copy uh
what we
have where is
it what we have uh written down before
we started started with this in the in
the beginning of the of the lecture well
it really holds each column is a
different it's a corresponds to
different variable or to some maybe
transformation of that variable and each
uh row corresponds to one specific data
point it's kind of table like Excel
table which which is telling you what
are what were your experiments
about so we
so we can write it like
this so our first uh First Column will
hold one variable in its n different
experiments and different uh
representations there will be
a second variable whatever it
is
and our let's say last last
variable uh should I should I better
call it like MP such that I distinguish
between the uh subscript p and the and
the vector and the vector
p x n
PN o sorry not
n this is first experiment second
experiment the last experiment
so let's let's try and uh and practice
some uh some uh Matrix
multiplications hope you are brave
enough for that so how will the how will
the X uh transpose look like
what we
will like
qualitatively we have columns for the
different uh different variables in The
Matrix X and rows for different
experiments if we do the transposition
well they should just exchange right so
our
first First Column will just hold well
that will be the the the first row so it
will hold information about each
variable in the first
experiment this guy stays but we have
second variable first experiment we
have last variable in the in the first
experiment the second row will
well what what what will what will just
happen with the with the with the
indices in our former Matrix X when we
were when we moved from one column to
another what happened our first index
just increase by
one yeah this is the transposed yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's it's not not not not
the not the result of the of the
multiplication yeah yet we will we will
come
there
uh
next yes one two so what what does it
mean for the second
column in the former Matrix X the when
when we shift it from the First Column
to the second column our uh first sub
index changed from 1 to two then from
two to three to three to four and and so
on yeah until we ended up with MP being
the being the first index telling us
telling us the telling us
what wait is it correct or or did I
already write the no first variable okay
yeah yeah good good first variable and
variable so now what we what we should
observe
is that we will be Shifting the second
index in the in this transpose
Matrix so of course
our diagonal or if we can talk about the
diagonal is staying staying untouched
over and B and B2
yeah so it's the inverse World these are
all the data points from the first
experiment all the
variables second experiment third
experiment and so on until we arrive
at oops at the last
experiment okay okay
and let's now do the
multiplication with this
guy
squ diagonal will be what squared what
squared one
one each element of
[Music]
no
no let's well how do how do we multiply
the the
matrices okay it was a good guess I I
almost bought it for a for a second
it is equivalent of Matlab well Matlab
is is doing multiplication of matrices
as no we don't do element wise element
wise it's no
no that's not the real
multiplication it's called hadamar
Product or something like that no no no
no no that that's a crazy that's crazy
mat actually if you if you want to do
the derivation with it so how do we
multiply the matrices
first row what's the algorithm yes we
take the first row and we multiply it
with the with the First Column so what
will we what will we get from the
multiplication squ ah so there are the
squares so we get
X11
squared plus X12 squared right we are
multiplying first row and the First
Column so you were just slightly off
with your with your
guess so
what what what will it be if we now turn
back to our old ugly notation with the
with the sums we can write it definitely
as a sort of a sum
uh what will this what this what do
these uh AES have in common which index
first or second first one first one and
it's the index index one and the second
index would would just uh
iterate we already know that we get
squares and this will go from K one
until until capital N good sum of
squares what will
happen what will happen next uh which
one do we want
to do we want to do let's let's see
let's let's
probably let's probably do the do the do
the first cross product so let's do
let's find out about this
element what will it what will it look
like
one this one here still the First Column
but the but the second row so we take
the second row from the first Matrix and
we take still the First Column from the
second Matrix
so this one
[Music]
oops so this one Still Still
Remains What do we get x21 * X11 x22 *
X12 and and and and x21 N X1 n what do
these uh these terms have in common and
what is so do we get sum of
squares no yeah we get something like
the cross products between between now
what well this first row is oh sorry
this second row is telling about the
second variable that that we have in our
data set the First Column
here is is is just uh saying again about
the first variable but what they have in
have in common the they are just uh
coming together at the point of so how
is it X2 1 * X1 1 X2 2 X1 two yeah so
they they are still uh they they are
still joined or they share the same
observation point so that means that we
probably
can the Red Dot will just just means
that that's the red multiplication is
not very well seen on the on the on the
Beamer but in the notes from the
lectures lecture it will be seen so that
says that we can again kind of bind them
with this kind of uh with this uh with
this kind of uh sum yeah and then we
just
say what would be the what would be the
formula what should we
write X
[Music]
2K this
guy that will be the second there there
there is very little there is no x x
xk2
X1
x1k exactly
okay huh which one next let's try to do
this one here so the so the first row
second column first row still the still
the red
guy and the second column
this is the blue
dot what what is
Switched like it's going to
be
K2
K2 no
and K to no this this is not this this
this cannot be this cannot become K2
whatever K
is so first
row has what there is always the first
index is one yeah so we should be
getting suspicious like okay there
should be
X1 and what is this second column the
first index is
always two
so let's let's just
assume that we will get something
something similar and and then write it
and then then then we can then we can
check it I
just clean it up a
bit okay one and so would it would it
work just scroll down a bit so can show
you better first throw
second column
X11 X11 if we start with K = 1 times x21
X2 1 X12 X12 times
x22 works and so on and so on so uh
actually we get the we get the the the
same same same term here uh should it
Surpise Ur us or
not should it surprise us or
[Music]
not very suggestive question
right it it it should shouldn't be
shouldn't be much uh much much
surprising because well we already know
we have proven it yeah very strong
strong thing we know that this Matrix is
symmetric so whatever happens above the
diagonal should have its Mirror Image
under under the
diagonal so with this logic we can of
course of course continue what should be
the the element I know it looks messy we
will tidy tidy it up so we have a first
row First Column first row second column
second row First Column what should what
should come here second row second
column ah I revealed too much
X2 k s X2 k s perfect and so on and and
and so forth well we already even even
know if we now uh plug
in let me scroll to where we
started where we started to talk about
this this ve Vector notation yeah this
was our first attempt to take Vector x
times Vector X and
uh doing the scalar multiplication of a
vector itself we just uh get the the the
square square of X so if we now
say
hm this could work even if we now take
our vector vector X as the as the first
variable well so
basically we
can we can be writing our covariance
Matrix in the
form X1 transpose X1
transpose where X1 is the is just the
vector which represents the first
variable measured in n n experiments and
the same way on we can start start to
fill the diagonal X1 transpose X1 time
X2 transpose
X2 until
X number of parameters number of
variables yeah this this is going to be
this is how our
diagonal this is how our diagonal going
to be to look like and we can start
apply applying very similar similar
thing uh thing here again we have we
have seen this we have done it just in
the just in a different context well sum
of YK
XK this this sum so some cross term but
they are sharing the same time index
experiment index we can conveniently
again write it with the through the
scaler
products so all these guys are now
become X1 tx2 X1
tx2 uh no need
to again take care about the specific
order scaler multiplication can can do
this uh until
what this is the row which belongs to X1
X1 X1 times with X1 it's so by itself by
X2 and
by the last
variable what can we what else we can
fill in let's fill
in well this should be the First Column
should be just mirror image of the first
row it's symmetric Matrix I cannot find
any more any more
surprises which means
so that I put this put this a bit too
much too much
down X1
transpose X and
P what's going to come
here if it's like a Sudoku now yeah the
sum has to be or there should be all the
numbers
used yeah X to
transpose
XMP yeah which should have also the
mirror image of course of course here
yeah that's how the symmetric matrices
look like so
it's quite quite fun what are the what
are the consequences of this this
Matrix uh if you if you see see it for
for a first time well you take one
Matrix you make make a copy of it trans
transpose it multiply them together and
you might think well all the information
about the X which I had there is lost
but it's actually actually not uh not
true you actually gained a lot of
insight into your into your data because
what if what if we now do
uh what is the notation that we use
here I want to mess up the notation let
me check the
notes V okay so what if we now do just
slide variation of this
Matrix very simple compared to all the
heavy stuff that we that we have done
today let's just divide it if we have a
lot of experiments we can divide it by
the number of n if we don't have a lot
of experiments the question is what is a
lot of experiments
um then we divide it by the X uh uh by
the uh n minus one so the number of
experiments divided by one well this is
easy operation this is just scaler so
the scaler will just basically appear in
in all these in all these
terms but uh what would be
then what would the what would the
term X1 transpose X1 / n
-1 which is
which is nothing else than 1 / nus1 sum
of X1 oh sorry X1
squar
k k goes from from one to n
h have we have we seen such a such a
thing ever ever before
and stand deviation standard deviation
exactly exactly or well it would be
standard deviation if it's square rooted
this one this one is is nothing else
than the than the variance of
X1 no
so the and that's just the first element
of this Matrix the first element of this
Matrix is telling us how the uh how the
X1 is uh
uh how the X1 is uh is is behaving
yeah let me just just recall where was
our standard deviation maybe this guy
here our standard
[Music]
deviation
yeah we call this vessel
correction the only only trick trick
here is uh that uh the formula that we
just got now is simpler because we
already can assume well let's Center our
data let's remove the the mean from from
our
data oh and then we then we get then we
get this
one that's fine
let's maybe add the note that
X is the data XR are
centered so basically uh in analyzing
this uh this this Matrix we can if we
continue along the diagonal what do we
what do we recover we would basically
just recover
the standard deviation Square or
variances
of of the
different of the different different
variables
yeah
XMP that's fine we can also also do that
do that
individually very interesting will be
will be the of diagonal elements so the
of diagonal elements are now
coming from
this uh from these uh cross terms so
they should tell us something about the
relation of X1 in with respect to to
X2 and this will
be what's the good notation yes and this
will
be again let's let's have some some
Sigma notation for them but uh let's
also attribute this cross terms uh to
the variable to the corresponding
corresponding variables so the cross
term here will be
between uh variable one variable two
variable one variable three variable one
variable four until the number of
variables now it becomes too many
indices
[Music]
and of course this is this is symmetric
so
whatever whatever happens here will also
happen um on the upper side of the of
the of the diagonal and uh well it
wouldn't be that
uh if X1 squar is a variance
of X1
then these uh cross terms this Sigma X1
X2 for example that will be so called a
covariance x of
X1 ciance of X1 with respect
to to X2
so if you Center your data uh even if
you let's let's say let's say you do do
not normalize just Center your data you
can already or defined this uh this sort
of a this sort of a matrix
um it will it will give you a bunch of
numbers and maybe these numbers if the
data is not normalized won't be quite
quite
comparable uh so what we can do is uh to
to see even a clearer image is to is to
say
um we either normalize our our data
before or what we can what we can just
uh do is maybe maybe easier way we can
do like the normalization of this of
this this covariance Matrix and the
normalization of the covariance Matrix
will be matri Matrix let's call it maybe
C there are different uh notations and
this will be this will be called
correlation
Matrix and the correlation
Matrix not the not without any heavy
Matrix
calculus let's let's construct it just
like like this if we have
[Music]
the element of this Matrix on the row I
with the with the column J well we just
take
the we just take
the the corresponding corresponding
element which would
mean from the from our covariance Matrix
v i j
and so how how is how is this working v
j so V VII or v11 is the is the co
variance of X1 the the second element or
the second row first First Column the
covariance of X1 X2 is at the V12
one
two one two because it's Al it's this
guy here one two or two one yeah because
it's the it's symmetric so if we now
take
uh standard deviation of not sorry not
X1 but x i standard deviation of of XJ
we
basically we basically uh get the get
the normal normalization and we can
guarantee that these numbers will will
happen between Min - one minus one and
one
um of course if we take if we take
diagonals yeah so let's just take
example of
C11 C11 will be we take
Sigma Square X1 the variance of
X1 and we divide by standard deviation
of X1 standard deviation of X1 what do
we
get yeah so
the for the covariance Matrix we can
pretty pretty
easily pretty easily expect that our
diagonals are our the the the diagonal
of this of this Matrix is is full of
ones it's the same thing as if we would
normalize our data so normalize means
that all the data points have the unit
uh unit standard deviation or unit
covariance the interesting stuff is
going to it's going to happen under and
above this Matrix I just put this sign
raw
because these
uh these CI J these off diagonal
elements will put will will turn into
into something that that has a special
special name and it's a so-called
correlation
coefficient correlation coefficient as
we
already
uh discussed we'll take numbers between
minus one and one that's good why is it
good because if I see this Matrix and
it's not particularly large let's say I
have uh maybe 10 variables then this is
10x 10 matrix then I can start to
compare the variables between between
itself you you have done it uh if you
already had this uh these these these U
exercises you You' you've already
already seen it in some example of a of
a destillation
column what I can start to conclude well
if the correlation
coefficient yeah and this will be again
like correlation coefficient IJ yeah
those are
these elements of this Matrix this CI J
so if
it's greater than zero we would say of
course it's a positive
correlation what does it mean positive
correlation in the in the simple terms
what does it mean if there if the two
variables have positive correlation what
can you what can you
tell maybe in the more child language or
simple language let's
say like temperature and pressure yeah
they they there are many systems where
they have positive correlations so
correlation so if the temperature
increases
pressure
increases something
like the way example it's positive
then increase the temperature increase
the pressure as well yeah exactly
negative
coration it's the other other other way
other way around yeah if one variable
increases another another
decreases uh
yeah there are of course physical
systems or systems where somebody will
tell you what these data are you can uh
deduce it you can you can judge it yeah
if you if you do the distillation column
uh example you will find out oh the
pressure at the top of the column and
the pressure of the bottom of the column
are positively correlated well that's
another discovery of AG we kind of have
this intuition because we have studied
separation processes and and stuff but
uh if you are given data that you have
no clue what where they are coming from
or what is what is hidden it's much much
harder um
so because this
uh these uh correlation coefficients
have this nice property that they are
just m between minus one and one so if
we just look at their uh absolute value
and we would find out out well okay this
is let's say greater or equal 0.8 these
are just rough numbers well then you
then you could conclude we have a strong
correlation if these
are let's say between
0.5 and this
0.8 maybe you can suspect that there is
some correlation
maybe you would say it's a it's a mild
mild correlation and Below
uh below
0.5 I wouldn't be uh depends on the
quality of your of your data but I
wouldn't be uh putting uh much more
attention like uh much more correlation
is is happening depends if raso the
exercises gives you some nicer data
maybe at the 0.5 something can can can
happen but uh
uh usually this doesn't mean complete
equivalence like there is no correlation
but you you cannot cannot really say uh
that uh that the the two variables would
be would be
correlated
uh I wanted to do a
small small exercise with our where did
we find this ah
sorry we were just discussing uh
discussing this age uh sometimes at this
uh at these uh reports from from our
faculty you find uh you find
interesting interesting numbers so this
is about the the mobilities where the
where the students where is the picture
ah this is strange PDF where the
students no this is
the where the students either come to
our
faculty from abroad or we have the or we
have the what is this uh students from
our faculty go
going going abroad
uh ah yes this is okay so students from
our faculty going abroad in different
different uh study study years uh or
academic academic year so we have one
data set and I don't know why our
uh uh our Deans and why why de uh
somehow put this into into one graph
with uh the number of foreign abroad
students coming to our faculty yeah so
here we here we have some numbers I've
done this I wanted to have bit more time
that we that we calculate the
correlation coefficient it's just five
numbers it's not the not the big
statistics but uh if you if you look at
this so this this is this is represented
uh represented graphically uh you might
start to notice like well maybe it seems
like if this uh if this variable is
decreasing also this variable is
decreasing and if this one is
increasing it it it it might be that uh
that we have increase maybe we have a we
have a light light decrease this is just
the note I I this calculation for for
these two variables you get the cor
correlation coefficient
0.7 so it is suggesting there is there
is some
correlation but then the question would
be uh does it make sense that these uh
variables are are correlated is this uh
just correlation or is this causality so
is there
is there some magical power uh if there
is less students in one Academic Year
deciding to go abroad for Erasmus and so
on is there some magical power that will
if there is less students from our
faculty going abroad that will hold the
students from all the world uh coming to
to to our faculty and it does doesn't
seem that that it's that it's uh that
it's there we can of course uh deduce
that there is some kind of common factor
uh which which will influence these yeah
that was the covid pandemics that that
reduced the these these numbers so just
the nice words at the end be careful
with the correlations not of them not
all of them means mean causality some of
them mean something else completely else
is happening yeah it doesn't doesn't
have
to the correlation does not have to
indicate that one variable has really
influence on
another any
questions okay if it's not the case